la gouvernance mondiale le monde est
devenu un village
les frontières ne permettent pas
d'arrêter les virus on a donc créé
l'organisation mondiale de la santé nih
les flux financiers
on a donc créé le fonds monétaire
international avec ces institutions
on tente d'organiser le monde on appelle
ça la gouvernance mondiale
s'il ya bien une activité qui ne connaît
plus de frontières c'est le commerce
voilà pourquoi l'organisation mondiale
du commerce est si important jean-paul
chef de l'entreprise fils chose c'est
quelque chose
il a repris la fabrique des chartes créé
par maurice son grand père après la
guerre on sait dans la sphère à son
petit fils maurice l'avait prévenu il
faudra certainement vendre l'usiné où la
fermer et licencié les 60 ouvriers parce
que depuis que la chine a adhéré à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce en
phil shaw ne peut plus suivre face à une
telle concurrence la france ne peut plus
taxer les écharpes chinoise comme elle
pouvait le faire avant pour protéger son
industrie textile
jean paul est furieux qu'on ait laissé
la chine adhérer à l'om c'est il trouve
que la concurrence n'est pas juste parce
que les chinois paix très mal leurs
ouvriers l'om c est basée à genève en
suisse
150 pays s'engagent à ne pas mettre de
barrières douanières trop élevé entre
eux le but c'est que le commerce soit le
plus libre et le plus fluide possible
pour que le plus grand nombre de pays
puissent acheter et vendre
s'il ya un conflit entre deux pays qui
voudraient par des moyens détournés
empêcher des importations ou des
exportations c'est l' omc qui tranche et
peut infliger des amendes aux tricheurs
en attendant à cause de la haine c'est
maurice inquiète pour jean paul et ses
employés mais jean paul est malin et au
salon du textile moderne à paris il a
rencontré odile odile est ingénieur et
elle a mis au point un tissu synthétique
ultra souple et ultra chaud grâce à une
formule toute simple à base de lait chut
c'est un secret de fabrication
odile et jean paul font affaire
l'entrepreneur décide d'investir pas mal
d'argent pour adapter l'usiné former les
ouvriers aux nouvelles techniques qui
permettront de fabriquer les écharpes
violettes avec le super tissu d'odile
oui parce que le seul inconvénient de ce
tissu sait qu'il ne peut être que violet
mais peu importe jean paul a eu l'idée
géniale depuis 2011 la russie a adhéré à
l'om c'est du coup la russie ne peut
plus taxer les écharpes venus du reste
du monde et en russie il fait très froid
jean paul parent moscou et propose ses
écharpes révolutionnaire en tissu super
chaud et il explique aux russes que la
mode à paris celle violet rosé non ils
mordent à l'hameçon
il en commande 25000 en constatant que
phil shaw est sauvé maurice est obligé
de reconnaître que l'om c'est a aussi de
bons côtés
le seul problème c'est qu'il n'aime
vraiment pas le violet